Hello Guillaume.
Hello Olivier.
Very happy to have you here.
It's me.
We're in Youtube's premises.
Yes, it's extraordinary,
beautiful studio.
Obviously, the quality of production
is somewhat higher compared to what we've done so far.
It's nice.
It's nice, it's nice.
I thought I'd make it available to you
since it's with you that we first started the videos anyway.
Yes yes, and then it's a great adventure, and we continue.
We must continue to develop something,
quietly, without disturbing anyone, but showing that we can bring things.
To begin,
I suggest to go back briefly on your journey
in aikido,
your beginnings, and then your departure for Japan.
Yeah ...
Quickly though...
Okay, let's do it quickly, we've done it already,
so it's not worth spending too much  time on it because I'm not [that important]...
Basically, I started martial arts at the age of 5, I started with fencing,
I did a little judo at school too, and
I practiced very intensively until about 14-15 years old.
At 14-15, as I was fencing with adults,
and always with the right hand, I had a bone deformity
and so I was forced to stop, and was told, "You should start swimming."
I said, "no thank you I don't like water that much."
"and I especially don't like pools."
So I was told, "find something that uses both hands", so I wanted to do kendo, which made sense.
I did some after, but at the time I was told,
"Not kendo, because the hands aren't parallel so don't do it."
So I said, "Well, I'm going to do karate."
I took my father to karate, he said, "my son, it's not for you."
So after that, by chance, there was another dojo not far from our house where they did aikido.
When I was fencing at Paris University Club, there was a dojo where I had seen Aikido
so I said "Oh that's not bad, I hope I can do that one day"
And so I took my father to see Aikido and it was, by chance,
since I did not know him at the time,
it was André Nocquet who gave the lessons.
We sat down with my dad and we watched a class.
At the end, Nocquet came and he thought it was my father who was going to register,
and he said to my father, "So, are you interested to register?"
My dad said, "Not at all, but you can register my son."
And that's how I started Aikido.
Because my dad wasn't into martial arts.
I started Aikido there, I was lucky because it was at the Dojo rue Servan ,
which subsequently burned so it no longer exists,
and the French kendo team was training there,
there were a lot of very interesting things.
When Christian Tissier came back from Japan,
he started to teach there on Wednesdays I think at the dojo rue Servan once a week.
That's where I met Christian.
After that I went to Christian's dojo in Vincennes
so I was among his first students actually.
We were 10 or 20 at the time.
It happened like that.
When i saw Christian, I discovered an entirely new world.
He had so much panache, it was so extraordinary,
I told myself: "what he's got, he found it in Japan".
There was nobody at the time who did that.
I told myself: "I have to go to Japan".
I was young, I was 17-18 years old,
and I say to Christian, "Well, I have to go to Japan."
And he said to me, "Come, I need to explain something to you"
"how much do you have in your bank account? "
I said, "Well, I worked all summer and all that," I was a kid,
I think I think I had 3800 francs, which at the time, wasn't much.
And he said to me,
"Listen, it's simple, when you have 3 times more, we'll be able to think about you getting you to Japan."
As I never had that, I didn't go.
Time went on,
I did my baccalaureate,
I did a BTS Assistant Engineer, after I did philosophy,
and when I finished my studies, I thought, "I'm never going to go."
So, I saved as much as I could and left for 3 months.
I've been here in Japan for the past 33 years now.
I went back to France for a small period to attend some business but basically that's it.
So 33 years at the Aikikai, not not only, because I also went to other dojo, and I did  Daito-ryu too.
All of that goes together.
When I went to Japan I was already 3rd dan and now I'm 6th dan.
Those aren't  references that, they're just a journey.
That's my journey.
In Japan, I was happy because even though I arrived after O Sensei's passing,
all the old Sensei of from the beginning of the Aikikai were still there,
except Chiba Sensei and Saotome Sensei, who had already left for the United States
but there were all the old ones, Yamaguchi Sensei, Arikawa Sensei,
Watanabe Sensei, Masuda Sensei, etc. they were about 20 Sensei.
And then, of course, there was Kisshomaru Ueshiba.
He deeply impressed me,
just like he deeply marked Christian in fact,
because Christian is really an emanation of Kisshomaru, I think.
That's it, to put it simply.
Later on, I started Daito-ryu in Japan.
It's been about 15 years now, something like that.
My path is a bit chaotic but at the same time, it's always going in the same direction,
it's the search for the truth, it's the only thing that matters to me,
to try to find what is true and what isn't,
to eliminate what isn't true, keep what's authentic and coherent.
There isn't  a lot of that if we look carefully.
It's a difficult path, it's not just about training, it's about also looking for,
in training and in what we are given in training
or in teaching, because it's also a teaching,
what is interesting for me first, but also what is interesting for the world in general.
And all that is false, all that is unauthentic for me,
- is not necessarily to be thrown in the trash, because it presents other interests, -
but it's a waste of time.
To put it simply.
What was the biggest difference between the Aikido you discovered in Japan at the Hombu Dojo compared to what you did in France?
It's a difficult question because it's a question
whose answer is working over time.
I mean that when you come from France,
I was a 3rd dan, I was in great shape, I used to do a lot of Thai boxing,
I was kind of smart ripped.
I had no problem with Aikido in particular,
I just had an identity problem, that is to say that
Christian's aikido fully satisfied me there was nothing wrong for me.
There was just one thing that bothered me,
it's the authenticity.
Christian was genuine because he had been to Japan,
and I wanted to find,
in my own aikido,
this authenticity in my practice.
Christian couldn't have brought that to me in spite of all his efforts.
It's a question of culture more than a matter of practice.
And so when I arrived,
technically speaking, the aikido they were doing here didn't impress me.
As a first impression, I didn't see much difference.
It wasn't necessarily better, they trained, it was easy going,
well, it could be quite rough at the Aikikai at the time, but I was used to that.
I'm a bit dingy, so it suited me well.
So I didn't see any big differences at first.
I was there for 3 months, and then I stayed.
I think it's thanks to Kisshomaru Ueshiba, that it changed.
I didn't go to the morning often, and one day, Gerard Sachs told me,
"Olivier I don't understand, why do not you come in the morning?
"It's a fundamental class"
"Especially for you who is always looking for things like that"
"Come train in the morning."
I said, "why not, I'll go".
It was a trigger I think.
I realized, well, behind the facade of the Aikikai's aikido,
there was maybe something else.
Kisshomaru Ueshiba very quickly took me
in confidence perhaps,
and I realized that he had an attention towards me that he didn't have for others.
I liked that.
I thought of it as a sort of recognition,
for the little, shabby stranger who was there
and who does his aikido the est he can.
When Kisshomaru came with a smile or showed you something a little different, you thought,
"He shows other things than what he shows others."
There are two worlds.
We call that a dichotomy in French.
That is to say, a distinction, a cut.
There is what's being shown, and there is what's behind.
That's what made me realize that if there was something behind, it was like a theater.
I love the theater. For me, it's really
I am a little antique in this sense, for me, theater is like life.
In theater you have the audience,
you have the stage with actors, and then you have the backstage.
And then after you have the administration and then you have the firemen, all of that.
And, in fact, people only look at the stage.
The scene it interests me, I met many actors like [Michel] Galabru, etc.
And talking to them is one thing, but seeing them on stage is something else.
So that's what actually happened.
I remember one day, I was working on TV,
I had lunch with Galabru, and then I realized he was not the same as when he was acting,
and that he was telling me things that were different from the image we had of him.
And that's exactly what happened with Kisshomaru Ueshiba.
He told me: "There is the aikido that you do, that you train with, etc., and then there is something else."
And that's where it clicked.
It took 2 years, maybe 3, I don't know anymore,
and I started to be interested in the backstage of Aikido...
Do you mean behind the scenes in terms of organization or...
In terms of organization, you can't really get much into the Japanese organization of Aikido.
It's almost impossible, even when speaking Japanese, because of the very Japanese nature of the organization.
It's an organization based on secrecy and on hierarchy
and hierarchy leads to secrecy,
that is, everything you don't need to know
we don't tell you.
For example, when you go to a Japanese administration to get some information,
you ask a question, and what the respond
is only what you need to know.
But sometimes, a question in French for example, has several possible solutions.
In Japan no, you are always given one solution,
the one who accommodates the one behind the counter,
and if you don't know that there are other solutions, you can't continue,
so you are directed straight away on sidelines,
because it is not always very direct.
It's what happens in Aikido.
You're told "Do ikkyo like that, do shiho nage like that, do as I do", etc.
So it's a derivation, you're told "Here, you have to go there". There is a sign that says, "That way".
I simplify, but that's it.
So I asked to myself, "Why is there a sign there? But there are other ways there, why is nobody going there? "
Because everyone follows the sign.
Kisshomaru was the first one to say to me, "Here you see, there's the sign, go there,"
"but at the same time, when you have time, well, go see a little bit elsewhere. "
That's the backstage.
We are quite content with what is practiced,
technically, and philosophical, since I speak of it too [in my book],
at all levels, thought, body, and heart too, relationships with people etc.
but behind all that, there are other worlds.
Several other worlds and these other worlds shape the facade,
but at different levels and at different depths,
and so it's very difficult to sort all of this because
It's a little searching for the needle in the haystack, especially if you have only one question.
So the idea is to try to take the haystack and to work out how it's made,
what goes with what, and how, and why, etc.
and then to try to see if there are connections,
and from these connections, to see if we can find the peasant who made the haystack.
It's a bit like that.
And why he did it like that and not otherwise and why.
So this book that I published recently tells that story.
Trying to clear up aikido and say,
there is everything that you are being told about this kind of stereotypical story about the life of O Sensei,
Harmony and all that,
Aikido is wonderful, etc.
And there are other untold things,
and that are sometimes better.
But why do not we say them? So also know why we do not say things,
or why we don't do the movements in a certain way.
for example, there are movements in irimi that we don't do anymore.
Recently, I was training with an uchi deshi of the Aikikai,
and I make him irimi omote.
He looked at me like that and said "we don't do that anymore."
I said, "Yes, why?"
"It's part of aikido, irimi omote, why don't we do it anymore?"
He said to me," Oh well that's too dangerous. "
What generation of uchi deshi?
An older generation, one who knew.
Because I doubt that the new ones can formulate this remark to you.
Yes, but the new ones don't make this remark to me, besides, they don't come to work with me because they're scared.
Well they're scared, no, I shouldn't say it like that, it's not a physical fear,
They are confronted with the unknown...
The Japanese have always...
It is a very cautious people.
They don't like the unknown, they like to know where they are going,
how things work, and I am opposite.
You said it to me often, when one works with me, one is not thrown, one falls, it's not the same.
An aikidoka who is used to being thrown, falling, etc., does not like falling
so that's the unknown for those people.
Not for me, because I saw so many things in terms of falls, etc.
Of course there is the formal fall, there is the fall of demonstrations.
It's great too, it's good.
But then there are other things, and so it's the same, it's the backstage.
So after a few years practicing Aikido in Japan, you came across Daito ryu, a little bit by chance.
How did it happen, what made you want to start?
So in fact it's not really a coincidence.
For a very long time, even when I was in France,
The name of Takeda Sokaku was already known to me and interested me
because when one is interested in the life of Aikido, as a virtual character,
we are necessarily interested in the life of O Sensei, that is to say, Ueshiba Morihei,
and so, what was there before?
Who taught him all these techniques?
There must have been someone, he didn't invent them like that,
it's not possible. Well, it could be possible but,
it's not coherent since there was the war and so on.
It was a subject that had interested me
but little by little, in France, and perhaps elsewhere too,
the very name of Takeda Sokaku disappeared from circulation,
that is to say, we spoke no more of it, like the ki, we don't talk about it, we don;t want to know anymore.
So over generations of practitioners,
people don't know at all, they don't even know the name.
That had been in my head for a very long time
and one day, by chance, that was indeed a coincidence.
My son was doing kendo in the police, and there was a big competition in which he was taking part.
And just as we were going out, there was a big sign where it was written:
"Today Daito-ryu seminar with Kobayashi Sensei."
so I went to the receptionist and said, "Hello, I would like to go to the Daito-ryu seminar."
She told me, "It's not possible", so I got angry.
I spoke good Japanese so it's ok, but I was so angry that they didn't let me in.
The director of the sports center came,
he said "Mr foreigner, you have to understand, it's a private seminar."
I said "If it's private why are you putting a sign outside?"
"So what's the point? It's private or it's not private."
"If you put a sign outside, it's for people to know, and if they know, it's so they can come in, so do something."
So they phoned the Sensei in the dojo,
and he sent an assistant and who told me:
"you can't watch Daito-ryu, it's pointless to watch it,"
"you won't see anything, you won't understand anything,"
"you will have a judgment that will be wrong,"
"so what we can do is, you give me your coordinates,"
"the next time we have a seminar in Tokyo, you come to practice."
"For free it's not a problem,"
"we offer you the first class if you want and then you can judge by yourself"
So I gave my phone number, thinking that they would never call back,
especially after the scene I had made.
And in fact, they called me back.
It was a month later, there was a new seminar, at another dojo, so I went there, I was was super happy about it.
What happened is that...
They welcomed me with open arms.
It surprised me even because in koryu dojo in Japan, it's rather:
"Do you have a letter of introduction?"
"Yes, I have one"
"Nah but you need two"
"Oh no, I have another"
"Oh yes, but you need three." It's a bit like that.
On the contrary, they welcomed me with open arms, it was Kobayashi [Kiyohiro] Sensei, super nice,
He said, "Do as we do, and see what happens"
And I practiced with Miki Sensei and I did Aikido!
He showed stuff that looked like Aikido so I did Aikido.
So I got them quite tired,
but they told me "But wait, you're moving like a madman"
"It's good but it's not quite like that."
"You'll have to get a little bit into the Daito-ryu way, during your first class at least"
"so that you understand what's going on."
And there, they started to do the movements on me a little differently.
It was a trigger too, I thought, "There's something going on."
"It's the same types of movements,"
"but as uke I'm not taken the same way, it's not like at the Aikikai"
"I feel something else is happening in my body."
So I became interested. I started like this.
And the more I did it,
the more interesting it became.
Not just because of Daito ryu.
Frankly, I didn't care much about Daito-ryu at first
it was in relation to the Aikido that I was doing it.
Could it bring me something in my Aikido?
Especially the connection between Takeda Sokaku and Uehsiba Morihei.
I could finally see physically
a kind of relationship in movements within the practice,
and I saw at the Aikikai that my aikido was changing.
And that was a real revelation.
How long did it take, for this change to take place?
It was very fast actually.
You have to understand one thing.
I injured my back pretty badly during boxing,
I really had back problems, I had a double hernia on the back
and it couldn't be operated because it was too delicate.
A famous Tokyo professor told me,
"Listen, you don't want to stop Aikido, do you?"
I said, "No, no, I don't stop, I'll die like Molière, on the mat."
And he said, "Then continue but you have to change you Aikido".
I said, "But how do I do it? Tell me"
He said, "But, I don't do aikido, it's you who's doing aikido, it's up to you."
And so from that day I changed. It was just before I started Daito-ryu, actually.
I started to change my aikido, that is,
to better try to feel, within my body, to read my body, as we say in Seitai.
That is to say, to understand what was happening, why I was hurting, the positions etc
What was wrong, why was my elbow hurting all of a sudden
whereas before it didn't hurt when doing this movement, etc.
This reading actually allowed me, in Daito-ryu shortly after, six months or a year after,
to understand that there were important things going on at the level of the body body level in Daito-ryu.what
With Kobayashi Sensei, it took maybe 6 months, a year but no more, and then I thought,
"Yeah, this is a revolution"
I went from something external, the stage, and I added the backstage,
so here the acting took all of its power, it was bingo.
Even with Christian, I had never felt these things.
It's really a question of sensation, it's not even a question of technique
because I didn't care about techniques, for me it was the same.
Daito-ryu, aikido, I didn't see the difference,
but what I felt was different even when I was doing it.
It took maybe 6 months, a year, and then what happened was
having put Aikido and Daito-ryu in relation, I noticed the differences,
little by little, it took maybe 3 years,
and then I went to Shikoku,
about 3 years later.
I went a bit like in Aikido,
from a standard Daito-ryu to more and more specific Daito-ryu.
While still looking for the source.
to look for the source, that's my big thing, it's almost an obsession,
whenever I do something, I look for the source.
What year was that when you met Kobayashi Sensei?
Two thousand...
We are in  2018,
In 2000, I was in France,
around 2005
roughly.
So 2 or 3 years later, you went to Shikoku...
And after, 2 or 3 years after, Shikoku yes.
I was introduced to Shikoku by Kobayashi Sensei
because, I asked him, "where does all that it come from?"
Just like that, nicely...
"Where do you train? As a Sensei, where do you train?"
That's a good question, we never ask Sensei "Where do you train?"
The sheer fact that he still trains [is surprising] even though he must already have been 8th dan, kyoju dairi...
He keep training.
Yes, he trains.
There is a lot of Aikido Sensei, in France and in Japan, who don't train anymore.
They don't train anymore.
It's one of the problems of Aikido.
Once someone is Sensei, Hanshi, Kyoshi, who knows what,
he's settled,
but that's not how it works.
Some are professionals,
but even a professionals in other disciplines still train.
A professional pianist does scales all day.
But they would tell you that they train on their students...
By teaching, but that's a joke.
Don't think people are fools.
When you teach, you learn things too
for sure, and another way to do Aikido, that's obvious.
But, like when you teach piano, like when you teach surfing, etc.
But it's not a training,
there is no questioning, that's the problem.
The problem is questioning.
A surfer for example, who is professional,
he's doing the big competitions, etc.
but he trains he goes to Biarritz, to Portugal, etc.
Why ? Because he knows very well that he has to constantly question himself.
In Aikido, there is no questioning, it's won in advance
I am Sensei so you obey... you cooperate...
And there's that kind of aura that makes the Sensei's uke... he's already won.
So it's easy.
it's a rigged game
don't mix authenticity with that sort of role play.
Yesterday, I trained with one of the young Sensei of the Aikikai.
I don't give him anything as a uke. I don't do it and he is happy!
He is happy !
Because
he tells me,
"At least, with you I feel I'm doing something, it's not as usual."
If I can sweep his leg and tip him over, I'll do it.
It's up to him to fend for himself.
You put the word on it, he's a young Sensei of the Aikikai.
Yes, but he is heavier than me!
Yes I understand, but in the hierarchy,
he arrived after you.
He arrived after me but hey, there are different hierarchies in Japan.
I understand, but I doubt if anyone who was there before you would have reacted so positively.
I did it with...
You need the means to do it. That is to say, you can't do whatever you like.
We're not in MMA, or anything
but what I mean is that the role of uke must be
not only a participant.
For me at least.
In France we say... well, it comes from Japan, actually...
we say that uke must be half of the movement.
I'm sorry but if uke is not an attacker,
we might as well play tennis.
We must also define what is meant by "half", that is to say, if we speak ...
He does half of the movement.
If we talk about katageiko,
uke does his job of attacking,
an attack as it should e done, it is not half of the movement in a kind of "submission" so that the movement works...
Yes, but that's what it's coming to.
Until the 1st dan, or even until the 4th dan if you want,
perhaps, that is, there is a connivance that must be in place to improve the movements, etc.
To also find one's strength, power, coordination, etc.
So it's a gymnastic work but gymnastic work does not have to go on forever.
Someone who has 10 years of Aikido
if he continues that way until the end of his life,
why is he continuing?
It's a personal pleasure,
he became Sensei, or he became this, he became that.
Me if there if someone who challenges me, even a beginner, I am super happy
because at least there I see if my movement corresponds to something coherent not.
If I'm never challenged,
or someone else, it's not just me, me, me, I do not care,
but when I practice, I need that the partner...
When I work with you, you're heavy, you move well, you're dangerous,
that's interesting.
That is to say that I actually do it, when I work with you,
can I do the aikido that I speak of?
That is the problem :
to say what we do and do what we say.
If we can do both,
say what we do and do what we say, then yes, okay.
But to be able to do that, the partner has to be there
and be consistent.
even if he is lighter, even if he is more flexible or if...
Consistent means that he is present,
that there is a really continual presence until the end of the movement, until he is immobilized.
He's here, he's not neutral or passive
He's not passive.
Or submissive...
He is not submissive, it is not an act of enslavement, aikido, not at all.
We just accept the context of the attack, say, katageiko, but...
We say OK, it's shomen uchi, but for example yesterday, with this young Sensei
I was working on yokomen uchi,
so during the whole class, I tried to touch him.
Not touch like that, to have a yokomen, and I got there once.
Once it's good!
I always say, in a class, if you make one great movement,
then you have won the day there, it's great!
Even an attack...
Yes, for example an attack.
Even a phase of movement, there, really you have
touched the heart of aiki.
Then okay.
Yes, yes, yes.
It can be a bit complicated here, you talked about Kobayashi Sensei, you talked about Shikoku.
Kobayashi Sensei is one of the founding members of the Takumakai.
Could you come back briefly to the Takumakai,
and why did you chose the Takumakai?
Was it just the occasion that made you come across the Takumakai,
and you continue with them, or did you
chose the Takumakai for particular reasons,
compared for example what would people of a lineage and Hokkaido or...
You can say that...
at the beginning that it was a coincidence since I came across this seminar,
it was in Tamachi, Tokyo
Where I was actually invited,
in anticipation but hey, I asked
to be able to participate so they invited me to do it.
That was pure chance, it could have been Roppokai, it could have been Kondo Sensei,
it could have been many other people.
Because there are a lot of [Daito-ryu] schools...
What you need to know is that Takumakai is very close to Aikido
so they have an approach of Daito-ryu that is more open.
Not a lot but, but more open than others
branches that are quite closed or
more traditional in a way.
So it's a coincidence and at the same time, it was perhaps easier to access.
It happened like that.
And then, when I got interested in the Takumakai,
at first I did not even know what it was.
I had heard about it but not much.
I said "well, there is a relationship with Aikido", and that interested me more
because among others, Kobayashi Sensei
had started more or less by aikido, actually.
So he always did his Daito-ryu compared to Aikido,
and even in what he teaches now,
we feel it very well.
- I have seen other daito ryu elsewhere -
There is an influence of Aikido in his technique.
When one says "an influence of aikido", one must be very clear:
it is an influence of Ueshiba.
From the Daito-ryu of Ueshiba Sensei.
Because he [Kobayashii] knew Ueshiba didn't he?
Exactly, he knew Ueshiba Sensei.
It's necessary to open a short parenthesis.
Ueshiba Sensei started with Daito-ryu
and he taught Daito-ryu,
even though he didn't have a teaching license from Takeda Sokaku.
He had it in a way...
but not of a higher level,
where he could have been independent.
He was Takeda's representative.
Yes, he was a representative, under guardianship let's say.
But in reality, when he taught,
he didn't do it under guardianship, but a little autonomously.
That's why there was a break with Takeda Sokaku, because he would have said
"But wait, you do not have the authorization to do that".
I simplify, it's a bit more complicated, but
if you want to know, read my book.
There is everything in it, it's good.
It's summarized so it's easy to read.
But basically that's what happened and so
Ueshiba Morihei is thought to have taught Aikido all his life,
which, in my opinion, is a mistake.
It's partly erroneuous let's say.
Why ?
Because at the beginning,
until 1942 he taught Daito-ryu.
So if you have doubts, try to get this...
it's not easy to have,
Good luck!
They are extremely rare copies,
but they have all the old Daito-ryu techniques that were done before the war.
Basically that's it.
There are several volumes, but this is just one.
You have here an innumerable number of techniques.
I show it to you to show that there are still proofs,
and that's not words in the air.
There is evidence, and if we can read the evidence,
you have to know how to read the proofs too, because if you look, like that ... yes good
and so Ueshiba taught Daito-ryu.
What happened is that in 1942,
because of the war, because of events with Takeda Sokaku etc.
there was a kind of break that was decided, that is to say that
the group that worked with Ueshiba decided to register the word "Aikido"
to the Japanese Ministry of Education,
so it was a bit like a patent in fact, that's it.
And so the word "aikido" was born in 1942 to the eye of the Japanese Ministry of Education.
However, Ueshiba Sensei did not
change his teaching, not at all, he just changed the way he taught.
This is what people don't understand.
That is to say, he continued to do his movements,
himself of course, with his own progression,
therefore his own progression which also concerned philosophy,
the way to look at the movements, etc.
and he
simplified
the curriculum of these techniques.
He synthesized all that, in his own way
There was Iwama, etc. that's a long story,
you refer to book, there is everything in it.
And it's at that time that students who started after 1942
saw the Aikido of O Sensei,
but O Sensei no longer taught the Daito-ryu that he was nonetheless still doing,
so the students could not
capture the techniques
of Daito-ryu as they should have been done.
They could see, but they couldn't do it, so they invented ways to get there.
Basically that's what happened.
And Kobayashi Sensei, from Takumakai,
began Aikido in these circumstances.
However, unlike others, he was also doing Daito-ryu.
He was doing both at the same time so he was able to extract
from Morihei Ueshiba's Aikido all that was done in Daito-ryu and in Aikido
because someone who does Daito-ryu can understand what is done in Aikido,
whereas someone who does Aikido can't understand what's done in Daito-ryu,
It's one way. That's what's great. Well, great, depends for who...
It's pretty interesting.
So Kobayashi Sensei was in the right place to record both versions of Aiki.
For me in fact there isn't "Aikido" and "Aiki-jujutsu", there is "Aiki".
Then it should be noted that the teacher of Kobayashi Sensei in Daito-ryu had himself learned from Ueshiba.
Absolutely. Hisa Sensei,
- It was for him that the Takumakai was founded -
was initially a student of Morihei Ueshiba
who was then co-opted by Takeda Sokaku.
And so Takeda Sokaku gave him the Menkyo Kaiden at the end
to show that, hey, he had
acquired the entire technical repertoire,
perhaps not the repertoire, but at least the technical knowledge,
- It's not the same -
of Daito-ryu.
But Hisa Takuma was originally a student of O Sensei,
but since O Sensei also taught Daito-ryu, there isn't a big difference,
it's just a difference, we're going to say, of personality.